this is an example of a commercial that
does everything
right they show they don't tell they
raise the stakes
constantly they make themselves into a
beautiful internet meme and all the
while
they make millions while they're doing
it i love it
but let's break it down shall we hello
welcome to marketing mondays where we
talk about the good marketing
the bad the difference and how you can
be a more informed consumer maybe even a
more informed marketer
yourself today we're taking a look at
flex tape which has taken the world by
storm
their youtube channel has 131 million
views which as far as i can tell is
mostly organic traffic earned media
meaning they didn't pay for it a lot of
it's just people coming in
because they want to watch their
commercials and why wouldn't they
you guys are about to see why this these
commercials are
so fun to watch not only that but are
also such good
ambassadors for the brand here so of
course we have our
lovely host mr phil swift to start us
off
hi phil swift here for flex tape the
super strong waterproof tape
okay let me slow you down there phil as
you guys probably know
phil swift takes a lot of inspiration it
seems from billy mays very similar uh
style presentation style
bombastic you know a real big fan of the
demonstrations honestly you live or die
by your demos you know we saw this with
oxiclean where they had
one little scoop clearing out an entire
basically
black abyss of water not only are you
entertained but you're like now you
believe in the product because they
didn't have to tell you
they showed you same thing with shamwow
you guys remember this time
look at this put on the spill turn it
over without even putting any pressure
50 percent of the cola right there you
follow me camera guy like that's
that's ridiculous it sells the product
they don't have to tell you anything
they don't just
tell you it's super absorbent you're
watching it happen live that's the
beauty of a demo and that's what makes
it so much
better than just telling somebody about
your product but of course flex tape
does more than that because unlike
oxiclean and shamwow which obviously did
very well flex tape's sort of
uniquely memeable these guys understand
how to get internet the internet all the
buyers and you know have marketers
talking about you
and i'm going to tell you guys why
because they know how to
raise the stakes in the oxyclean
commercial
you know we see them clean stuff up but
it mostly stays
in household usage flex tape though
constantly is raising the stakes
throughout this commercial what does
that mean well it means
this after showing you they can patch
something from the outside uh they show
you they can patch something from the
inside
which is harder to do mixtape's powerful
adhesive is so strong
it even works underwater they move from
that to an even more improbable
achievement lifting a 45 pound plate
like an absolute
unit mr phil swift flex tape is super
strong and once it's on it holds on
tight like if you didn't believe in flex
tape already this convinces you
and then of course uh the absolute
internet meme of the moment is of course
this where they saw a boat in half to
prove the power of flex tape
i saw this boat in half
again it's hard to you know understate
how different this is from a lot of old
marketers where they'll stay within the
house
this they're taking it to the internet
memeable level it's the reason that
people like jontron have reacted to him
for 61 million views
you think that if he just patched one
hole he'd be reacted to no
they know to be bombastic to be
ridiculous
that's how you get people talking about
you that's how you bring people in
and it's also by the way the ultimate
test of this product obviously
leaks are the hardest thing to patch so
rather than like telling you oh it can
repair a broom handle they don't even
waste time with that they immediately
jump to leaks
and then they go to the biggest leak of
all a boat being
literally in half but it creates a super
strong water tight seal
so the inside is completely dry
yeah uh
yeah phil feels lovable too but um part
a lot of this commercial is really
working off the well-crafted
show don't tell the raising of the
stakes and just kind of
understanding what the internet's going
to react to and these guys aren't
one-trick ponies either they're
constantly doing this
leveling up the game raising the stakes
so first it was like saw a boat in half
then it's blow a boat in half i'm gonna
blast huge holes through the bottom of
that boat
with this giant cannon ready
remember we're talking about adhesives
which are hard to make exciting
but this i'm entertained you know we're
making
a reaction video about it everyone's
made reaction videos about this
and for good reason this is how you do
good marketing
you generate the buzz you don't wait for
the buzz to come for you
you shoot up you shoot a freaking cannon
in the hole of a boat that's what you do
absurd
it's like good videography to be honest
yeah these guys just clearly
understand the internet at a level that
most marketers do not
they're willing to pay the price for a
great commercial so what's the takeaway
here if you're a marketer watching this
video well
it's a few things no matter what you can
make your product exciting if a rubber
adhesive can be exciting
you can make your product exciting there
are no complaints you know i see so many
people they try to tell you how great
their product is or they spend too much
time in exposition
and it's just never going to be as good
as seeing a man
cut into a barrel with the chainsaw
it's just not and we as an audience
don't walk away
remembering that so you guys could learn
a lot from this guy because honestly
behind this bombastic personality
there's a really thoughtful guy
who understands marketing who
understands you know how
people think and honestly it's genius it
comes off effortless
but that's what makes it genius
marketing the other thing of course is
to lean
into the meme and always be raising the
stakes guys
he's always going to the next level
obviously after cutting the boat in half
that's not enough anymore right so he's
got this ridiculous chicken
demonstration which is very visual
whatever and he's going to make a boat
out of chicken wire so now
he doesn't even have a he doesn't have a
scaffold of a boat that he's got chicken
wire
constantly raising the stakes getting
you back invested
because you want to see is he going to
fail is he going to succeed you know all
that kind of stuff
and then the final thing i would say is
that uh yeah it's just a good
product i mean these products have been
tested by several people on youtube
who've you know seen can you make a boat
that's waterproof and the answer is
actually yes the product actually works
one thing i see a lot of marketers get
wrong is they end up backing bad
products and then they complain they
can't market them while it's like yeah
well if you don't have a great product
it's going to be tough
unless you want to lie which you
shouldn't do this is really honestly the
combination and it shows what's possible
when you have a great product
meet great marketers and meet some
internet
sort of know-how because the amount of
earned media these people have generated
is ridiculous this one video by jontron
has 61 million views of free traffic for
flex day there's other videos with
similar types of numbers
oh there's another video 23 million
views 4 million views 4.7 million views
this product is
absolutely viral and it's totally due to
the marketing nobody would be talking
about this
if it weren't for the great marketing
and honestly it's a great story
of what's possible i think they're a
family business so um you know i'm just
really happy for these guys and they
need to keep doing what they're doing
they obviously have it figured out and
you at home i hope you learned something
do you guys like these positive messages
i feel like i just talked positively i
know sometimes we have a negative spin
here but
sometimes i like going positive with it
flex tape great product great marketing
you can learn a lot
from how they do it hope you enjoyed
this episode of marketing mondays leave
a comment down below
for what you guys want to see next and
we'll try to cover it good marketing fad
marketing it doesn't matter
we'll talk about it we'll just we'll
analyze it together so
thanks for watching i'll see you in the
next one
[Music]